the jurgen experience
my first joke was something about
michael jackson
yeah and that was it that's all i
remember did you write anything out
before you went up there did you
no well i i tried writing but my hand my
penmanship is so bad been coming out of
public school it's a damn shame when you
can't even read your own [ __ ] so
and my spelling is terrible so that it
was
like okay it's michael jackson what did
i think about michael jackson i took it
from there so did did you rehearse it in
your head like how did you do it i
rehearsed it in the mirror like most
comedians
and you know the toothbrushes are
hollowing and the two places standing up
and
everything but it didn't translate on
the stage that time because when i first
started doing i just look up
unfortunately looking up at the sky
up at the roof of the place like a woman
ain't making love for money you know
what i'm saying ain't enjoying it at all
so i am um that's how i got down for my
first one
so you just didn't know where to look
um
did you feel uncomfortable like trying
to the insecurity that's why my name is
earthquake
you know and people keep asking me why
your name earthquake i say the reason i
named my name earthquake because if this
[ __ ] don't work out
i ain't gonna mess up my good names
so
somebody coming they say hey what's up
earthquake hey my name is nathaniel i
don't know earthquake he was earthquake
he was starting nah
that was my brother or somebody but my
name is nathan you don't even know no
earthquake that's hilarious i thought it
was just from the reaction you got from
the crowd no it was an insecurity that
if this don't work out
i did not [ __ ] up my goodness
that's hilarious because i thought it
was the total opposite i thought it was
a cocky move no like you're about to
cause an earthquake no it was like no
if this
this don't work out baby
you know what i mean i wouldn't be
scared i wouldn't scully my good name
it's funny because it's a perfect name
for you oh thank you it really is it's
like it's in the insecurity of want to
protect your name you literally came up
with the best nickname ever for you yes
yeah and that's how it came i used to
tell the joke people like how you came
into the earthquake uh this has happened
when your mother take heavy precautions
and not to have a child and you still
get pregnant you haven't it's nothing
else you can name that child but a
natural disaster
that's what i wrote as a joke for it but
the truth honestly about it was the
insecurity that if this don't work
i don't want to mess up my name were you
living in florida at the time i lived in
florida when i got out i went to atlanta
and then from when going to atlanta
that's when i started seeing what the
comedy clubs was like and
that's when we started opening my club
two years later so that is so you do
open mic
two years later you have your own club
and you're going on every day yeah
wow so every you gotta understand i'm
i'm tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday and sunday three shows on
fridays and saturdays
one on tuesday one on wednesday one on
thursday two on sunday every day for
about four straight years
wow
then it just
and you're doing like an hour every
night every show every show
off the top have you ever read the book
outliers no it's a great book is that a
malcolm
who is that
no
it's um someone else
is malcolm gladwell it's a great book
one of the things it's about is uh they
detail
people who are extremely successful and
he talks about the amount of time that's
required to get really good at something
and how many people that look like
overnight successes
the amount of time they put in was
extraordinary one of the things he talks
about is the beatles and the beatles
they did all these shows in germany
where they were doing like what you were
doing or they were doing every [ __ ]
night they were doing shows and they had
put in hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours doing these shows and
so when they first you know air quote
made it on the scene they had put in so
much time performing so much different
than most bands because they had done so
many shows nightly over and over and
over again
yeah there's no substitute for that not
at all and
it's the foundation of who i am
so when i have to sit here i close i go
in with the confident knowing all i got
to do is make sure my environment is
pure for me to be able to write the way
i do keep my mind straight and i can
come up with our
i didn't come up with album and when you
were doing this
like two years in is a very unusual
that's that's not a lot of time for
someone to be
forget about headlining at all but
headlining every [ __ ] night yeah and
basically doing being the whole show
every night yeah
we was um we would get some comedians
that come on it but we didn't get any of
the main
um comedians because uh
comedy act wasn't happening that's such
a cocky move to open up your own club
two years in that's amazing but they
were so vulnerable they was in the bad
bad part of town they didn't serve uh
food and then they the cotton spin
morning i mean the one that really would
bring them down they were so arrogant
with it that they had booked a comic
2 comic for the whole month
same comic every week
every week oh that's crazy yes i
remember it was joe torre
um joe torre and ted carpenter and they
did the whole month so when i brought my
investors there to get the club i said
look these same two gonna be here
there's 400 people in here they got two
waitresses plus they ain't got no food
plus they're in the bad part of town so
what we're gonna do we're gonna put it
we're gonna put the club in buckhead
black people don't go there that much
right there because they don't go there
we're gonna call it uptown
and we're gonna we're gonna serve food
we're gonna have valet service we're
gonna be in a better part of the town
and that's how you got it so once you
any if you're gonna go up against
anybody you first gotta recognize their
weakness and where you can draw from
what they got and that's why i pivoted
all my commercials to him that way are
you tired of going down to a place you
pocket car
and you might don't know who to be there
and they're begging you for money nah
come get your jokes up at uptown comedy
corner you know what i'm saying we you
don't see the same comedian over and
over again and we have food
and we have prompt service and
everything else come to uptown so i just
and as you sit there you give them a
comparison by the time people like yeah
we like it that's how i got them that's
amazing though that you did that two
years in like
go from your career in the military
where you kind of half-ass it you're not
really into it and then all of a sudden
you find this new thing
and you're all in
yeah you're all in you're opening up
your own club 24 months in that's crazy
but what you know it was out of
necessity because i got tired of driving
night
all the way to lakeland florida to get
fifty dollars a show and then the
biggest one you'll tell a woman you're a
comedian and she's like oh i ain't never
seen you at the comedy act you know we
segregation we're segregated in the
black community if you ain't here then
you ain't doing it you know what i mean
so it ain't done just it wasn't as
expanded as it is now that they can even
imagine this other club this was the
club of all club the only club if you
didn't work there you weren't no black
comedian
so you had this in your head that you
wanted to do this
and how did you make that happen like
who did you get to invest in it like how
did you start a club well it was this
dude named gary abdul he was booked he
was a comedian too and but he booked
things in like um
he used to do little little small places
like denny's for example and put a
plywood box up there little small place
sit there and he'll throw a show and
he'll book me
to pay me 150 me ricky smiley rest up
and we sit down and say what you need to
do is we need to open up a black club so
i showed it to him
and i said this is how we can get him
what i previously said said good idea so
we all went out and tried to get
investors i went to all dion sanders
dominique all the people in atlanta hey
man sean
just call this person call this person
[ __ ] ain't never do nothing
one one of the person was real one
person represented was very honest with
you listen man
quick i get five of these calls a day he
ain't gonna do [ __ ] i'm just
he can't go to that man ain't gonna
waste your time you know what i mean so
lucky um gary found um the number one
plastic surgeon in atlanta
and he invests but he told us
give y'all ten thousand dollars if y'all
can flip this
and show it can work on the small stage
then i'll get the club so we went to
birmingham a couple places and turned 10
into about 50 to 60 000. and then when
we get that from that point on he said
you could do it and he gave us the half
a million dollars to get the club wow
yeah
dr tom wow rest in peace my brother wow
yeah white dude was great he um he's
give put all the titties in the women in
atlanta george
[Laughter]
he was the titty specialist you know
what i mean so have you seen any big
titties in the 90s in the early 2000s it
was dr dob and how did you know him i
didn't um my partner gary at the time
knew him and he brought him in and we
got together he said i found somebody i
could do it but just the stipulation for
us to do it
and uh when i met him and i i was cool
it was beautiful
do you remember the opening night
yes
we had 15 people
yeah
wow yeah it was 15 people i'm so
surprised
it hold um 250
yeah yeah 250 people
some of the people matter of fact um my
video person who handles my media
for me um star um she was um that's how
we met i hired her as my waitress
and we've been friends ever since wow
then i gave her a job to handle all my
um my social media wow
so go from there 15 people yes and was
you the first guy on stage yeah i had a
couple of uh comedians to um
help me out
but i was the the main man until we was
able because he wants that club closed
then all the comedians oh man i'm sorry
man
then i'm gonna get down because now
you're the only comedy club in the city
right you know what i mean but till then
it was a battle and it was it was a
blessing in disguise because it made me
the beast that i am today when did it
start to catch on
after steve left
one steve and steve he taught me so much
you know because when he came he said
i'm gonna do your club cause i couldn't
get no headliners nobody that could draw
and i was like steve would you do it he
was hosting showtime they probably said
i'd do it for you
and he came in on a wednesday
and it was only about
30 people in there and i was like
and he came in and look he said
give him all their money back
and um come pick me up tomorrow at five
o'clock when we do media
i said what do you mean there's 30
people in here is that steve harvey
don't do no show for 30 people
okay then
and then i i picked him up and he took
me to the radio that's when i learned
how powerful media
and he stopped by he said let's start by
dunking donuts because we got to get
some donuts and some some orange juice
because you got to smooth these jocks
egos because
they feel you're going to try to take
their [ __ ] job and everything you got
to be good on them
and he um
we got in there at 5 30
stayed on from 6 to 9.
i tell you joe
when we got back
he had sold out two on thursday four on
friday four on saturday and two on
sunday
back in 93 i wrote him a check full 45
000 i didn't even know that kind of
money exists in comedy i was like oh
yeah i ain't never going nowhere i ain't
never going nowhere and when i saw him
pick up that kind of money and see what
kind of money can be generated
as a comedian
i'll say
this where i need to be and once all of
those people came and seen
all the things that club had to offer
and we was at and we had valet servers
and all the things that it could do
it was no turning back after that and
they saw me so it was great wow that
will change the whole game
that's a great story
you